[Musique]
tu va alerter les gens mauvais temps
parce que là ça arrive quand même assez
fort quoi je crois que la neige là ça va
tomber pas mal
[Musique]
au son de l'orgue sous les voûtes de la
cathédrale anglaise de salisbury
il n'y a pas que des fidèles le temps
d'une journée elle est transformée en
centre de vaccination depuis 800 ans
la cathédrale est là pour servir le
peuple de dieu aujourd'hui c'est la
meilleure façon de le faire
le vaccin sera-t-il rédempteur au pied
de la statue du christ à rio de janeiro
la campagne nationale et lancé de façon
symbolique
c'est ce qu'on appelle un blockbuster
pharmaceutique avec des ventes estimées
à 15 milliards de dollars en 2021
le vaccin développé par pfizer bio and
take pourrait devenir le médicament le
plus rentable de tous les temps devant
le lipitor un traitement anti
cholestérol également détenu par la
firme américaine et ses 12 milliards de
dollars de chiffre d'affaires chaque
année entre 2000 et 2010 connaît
effectivement c'est ce petit mois le
quai le financier mais si c est si ben
écoute ça à plus de 100 ans environ à
peu près un rôle à cet effet dans ce
quartier il a une forme de lingots qui
représente le lingot d'or et puis aussi
les très riche en beurre y à du beurre
désherbage je pense faire du baron
saisir les députés eux ne connaissent
pas la crise leur enveloppe de frais va
être augmenté de 15% en effet c'est le
député de l'assemblée nationale florent
bacheliers qui a pris la décision
d'augmenter de 15% le portefeuille de
dotation de tous les députés qui ne
s'agit pas de leur salaire il s'agit
tout de même d'une enveloppe qui leur
permet la prise en charge d'un certain
nombre de dépenses
parmi lesquels les courses en taxi ou en
vtc les dépenses téléphoniques ou de
courriers par exemple en cette période
difficile cette dotation annuelle est
passée de 18 mille neuf cent cinquante
euros à 21500 euros
accusée dénoncé fautif coupable oui
enfin changement que certains dénoncent
c'est le cas par exemple de la députée
la république en marche lauriane rossi
augmenter cette enveloppe dans le
contexte actuel ne se justifiait pas
c'est très difficilement explicable de
son côté eric ciotti persiste et signe
pour lui cette polémique n'a pas lieu
d'être cette augmentation est légitime
surtout qu'elle ne coûtera pas plus cher
aux contribuables puisque elle a été
financée par les économies réalisées par
l'assemblée nationale
dimanche 31 janvier c'était la date
limite de soumission des candidatures
pour le prix nobel de la paix 2021 dans
la presse plusieurs noms ont circulé
comme celui de l'actif pour le climat
great attenberg de l'opposant russe
alexeï navalni ou de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
mais d'autres nominations plus clivante
ont fait bondir certains internautes qui
estiment que le prix nobel perd toute sa
crédibilité en proposant les noms de
donald trump ou de son gendre jared
kushner je sais pas j'ai vraiment une
très bonne connexion avec les arbres
j'adore depuis que je suis tout petit et
c'est une façon de leur dire merci pour
tout l'oxygène que vous me donnez aussi
de vala que tous nos pardon parce que
c'est vrai que que l'humain n'est pas
très on va dire un groupe cool avec avec
la nature selon le site du prix nobel en
plus des anciens lauréats tous les
membres des parlements des gouvernements
ainsi que les professeurs d'université
et bien d'autres peuvent proposer les
noms résultats en 2012
un député ump avait proposé le nom de
nicolas sarkozy ce qui est bien pratique
pour être supposément en lice d'autres
candidatures farfelues peuvent aussi
apparaître comme celle d'adolphe hitler
proposé en 1939 par un député anti
fascistes de suédois qui souhaitaient
critiqué le fonctionnement du prix
espèce en voie de disparition
le bisou on a appris hier dans le point
qu'en anglais de 19 ans vient de se
réveiller après onze mois de coma le
réveil risque d'être un peu brutal
à son réveil il ya quelques jours c'est
avec stupéfaction qu'il a découvert un
tout nouveau monde un monde avec des
masques des gestes barrières et 100
restaurants
s'il n'est pas encore tout à fait en
état de comprendre l'étendue de la
pandémie liée à la cobi 19 sa famille
d'être petit à petit a remarché tout en
lui expliquant à quoi ressemble ce
nouveau monde dont il ne connaît rien
[Applaudissements]
je vais trop loin je n'ai pas bougé vol
moi non c'est pas un objet une femme et
toi moments pareils ton mari que tu sois
soumise est pas non plus te laisser
faire non plus non mais c'est vrai ça va
dans les deux sens je veux pas que il
est sympa a manqué que la tienne ont
pour objet mais je vais pas non plus ma
fille soit l'objet c'est pas parce
qu'elle est mariée que elle doit tout
subir non les choses normales qui
commande dans la famille qui commande
c'est l'armée qui commande
moi j'étais misogyne internaliser vous
étiez misogyne bien sûr j'étais misogyne
puisque j'ai grandi avec l'idée que
chaque femme était une concurrente une
rivale que du coup spontanément j'avais
tendance à jalouser vachement et à
envier vachement une femme qui était un
endroit où j'arrivais pas à aller tout
ça là aujourd'hui c'est de là que des
constructions ça me demande encore
beaucoup de travail mais en fait plus
j'ai travaillé plus j'arrive à attendre
juste une grande joie en fait à chaque
fois que je vois un succès d'une femme
vous avez fumé de l'herbe à 7 ans oui
qui avec votre frère en plus
ouais c'est moi qui ai eu l'idée vous
votre frère de 10 ans ont fumé de
l'herbe à 7 ans moi d'accord et quand
vous êtes procuré l'herbe mais c'était
de la pelouse
en fait on n'a pas foulé la pelouse mais
je comprenais pas pourquoi il y avait
vraiment voilà ça coûtait très cher je
comprenais pas j mais pourquoi ils font
ça il y en a plein dans le jardin qui
saute pas n'est pas marseillais
ok qui ne saute pas n'est pas
marseillais
ouais et je vous propose une autre qui
saute pas n'est pas là qu'on dise en
tapant départ
et on a profité de mon papa avait tendu
la pelouse et on a pris une feuille
d'école à 4 il avait roulé de l'herbe
oui non n'a jamais fumé parce que ça a
pris feu donc on a laissé tomber la
drogue c'est de la merde hein je le
rappelle le conducteur leur présente
alors un autre document encore plus
étonnant c'est bien a permis mais pas le
bon ça permet de plonger un permis de
plonger délivré par le ministère de
l'intérieur libyen mais signé à tunis le
tout écrit en français bonjour monsieur
c'est pas pour votre permis de conduire
c'est un permis de plonger je suis
content de moi franchement plainte je me
tire ma révérence
[Musique]